when it comes to crowdfunding where do
you see most filmmakers failing okay
it's way easier to fail at a
crowdfunding campaign that it is to
succeed and I think we are finally
moving away from this idea that if you
build it they will come
a crowdfunding platform is not going to
make you succeed so we have the highest
success rate in the business we have a
near 80% campaign success rate and
that's because we spend several stages
of feedback with our filmmakers before
we say yes we think you're ready to
crowdfund just like making a film your
crowdfunding campaign generally speaking
is won or lost in the pre-production and
then your ability to execute on the plan
you put together in the pre-production
the other thing is that the word crowd
funding is a compound word there are two
words in that word and the first word is
not there because it's a prettier word
it's there because it's the more
important word you cannot get funding if
you do not already have the crowd so
filmmakers often make the mistake and
actually people in general in
crowdfunding make the mistake that your
crowdfunding is where you do your
audience building no crowdfunding is a
phase and it's not the first phase of
audience building that you are doing
throughout your entire career right so
you have to be able to prove through
message testing which is something that
we teach basically interacting with your
crowd a lot to figure out what they like
and what they don't like you have to
prove to yourself that you can get total
strangers to click on the stuff that you
are offering before you should ever
launch a crowdfunding campaign otherwise
you're going to stay inside just your
friends and family right so I think a
common misperception is that oh it's the
crowdfunding platforms job to find the
non friends and family and I can tell
you that landing on the homepage of even
the biggest crowdfunding platforms on
average filmmakers see only a 4% bump in
there and this is true for us as well
like landing on the homepage doesn't get
you a ginormous bump in strangers you
get yourself to your audience and the I
think the primacy of the platform is
actually kind of problematic insofar as
you know they think oh if I go on one of
the big platforms that's where all the
strangers will find me no you have to
find the strangers and tell them where
you are that's actually how crowdfunding
really succeeds and the way that you do
that is you get really really specific
about who your audience is where they
hang out and how they like to be talked
to and therefore how you reach them
you